on Friday our nation once again
celebrated one of its highest and most
sacred holy days the trans day of
visibility it's very important that we
have this special occasion dedicated to
making trans people feel visible you
know there's an urgent need here because
other than the fact that trans people
are relentlessly celebrated and promoted
and elevated and worshiped by every
major corporation and by every
governmental institution and by most of
the most uh you know prominent and
powerful people in our country other
than all that trans people are
practically invisible trans people are
indeed horribly marginalized that is if
you don't take into account the trans
Pride flags hanging all over the place
and you know the trans propaganda shoved
in front of our faces everywhere we go
and the well-funded and coordinated
campaign to promote transgenderism and
recruit our children into it
um putting all that aside
trans people are really getting the cold
shoulder from society I mean if you if
you somehow didn't notice that all of
our most powerful institutions are lying
prostrate on the ground groveling at the
feet of this tiny minority then trans
day of visibility was likely a very
educational day
what I'm saying is that if you happen to
have been walking through life
blindfolded with earplugs for the past
decade or so then this sort of awareness
campaign was made just for you okay then
you probably were walking around on
Friday like trans people what's that I
had never heard of this before
but if you have been even vaguely
conscious and aware prior to Friday then
uh trans day of visibility may have
seemed a bit redundant you know trans
day of visibility that's just another
way of saying it's a day it's and it's
just a day on the calendar
and nevertheless the uh the day was
dutifully commemorated corporations and
Brands paid homage government agencies
displayed their fealty even the National
Weather Service put out a trans day of
visibility statement because no
government agency no institution is
allowed to just be what it is and focus
on uh you know fulfilling the tasks that
it was that it was made to fulfill no
because the the primary uh Duty now of
every institution is to
show their support and loyalty to the
LGBT alphabet soup and especially trans
people of course Joe Biden issued a
presidential Proclamation which somehow
manages to be even more ingratiating and
groveling than you would expect the
statement is lengthy goes on for
paragraphs and paragraphs but here's a
piece of it he says
transgender day of visibility celebrates
the joy strength and absolute courage of
some of the bravest people I know people
who have too often had to put their jobs
relationships and lives on the line just
to be their true selves today we show
millions of transgender and non-binary
Americans that we see them they belong
and they should be treated with dignity
and respect their courage has given
countless others strength but no one
should have to be brave just to be
themselves every American deserves that
freedom transgender Americans shape our
nation's Soul proudly serving in the
military curing deadly diseases holding
elected office running thriving
businesses fighting for justice raising
families and much more as kids they
deserve what every child deserves the
chance to learn and safe and supportive
schools to develop meaningful
friendships and to openly uh to live
openly and honestly as adults they
deserve the same rights enjoyed by every
American including equal access to
health care housing and jobs and the
chance to age with Grace as senior
citizens but today too many transgender
Americans are still denied those rights
and freedoms
now all of that is completely bogus
they're not denied any of that at all
period but
they he is right that trans people shape
our nation's soul
in a way not the way he intends he's
correct
our nation's Soul has been shaped or
misshaped deformed if you will by its
acceptance and promotion of an
acquiescence to gender ideology it
shapes our soul it defines us as a
nation in fact as far as the history
books are concerned uh quote unquote
transgenderism will be one of the only
relevant facts about our era
you know every era of in world history
is going to be inevitably to be defined
and it's going to inevitably boil down
to just a couple of things
and this is one of our things
it will be the thing that our
descendants look back upon with
astonishment and confusion
so Biden is closer to the markier than
he intended to be
but as we've established every day is
trans day of visibility so it continued
on Saturday in Vancouver where
anti-gender ideology activist Chris
Elston who goes by billboard Chris on
Twitter and he does he's been doing
great work on this uh on this topic and
he's been in this fight for years now he
showed up as he often does to peacefully
counter protest a pro-trans rally and
for him counter protesting just means
that he wears a billboard
um and in this case I think the sign
said children cannot consent to puberty
blockers
and he wears a billboard and he goes
around he talks to people and that's
what he did at this rally have you ever
read the fine print that appears when
you start browsing in incognito mode it
says that your activity might still be
visible to your employer or your school
your internet service provider to
actually stop people from monitoring
your online activity you need to do what
I do and use expressvpn think about all
the times you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee
shop Hotel even a friend's house without
expressvpn every site you visit can be
logged by the Admin of that Network
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode expressvpn is an app that
encrypts all of your network data and
reroutes it through a network of secure
servers so that your private online
activity stays private expressvpn works
on all your devices it's super easy to
use the app has one button you tap it to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure stop letting strangers invade
your online privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show use my
Link at expressvpn.com Matt will show to
get three extra months free that's
exprssvpn.com Matt Walsh show while
Vancouver Police watched and for one of
the cops anyway smiled Elston was
accosted and then physically assaulted
by a trans identified person who knows
that he the trans identify person has
implicit permission to act out as
violently as he wants and he decided as
we could see here to take full advantage
of that privilege watch
why do you think that they're getting
that kind of representation I mean it's
uh clearly was uh aggressive violence
you suck you suck you you you're
not wanted you you're you're a
idiot you're I don't know what to say
these police are mostly indoctrinated as
well
they're afraid of the mob
you're afraid they do anything
thank you
on the end of this abuse
people probably wanna how do you keep
your closure yeah what's up how do you
keep your exposure hey
so
um that's about as straightforward as
assault can get and we had to bleep it
out there so it might have been well
it's probably not that confusing but the
whole crowd was screaming Fu at uh
Elston and then the man with the long
hair and lipstick in particular was
right up in elston's face like six
inches from his face screaming Fu while
he's trying to do an interview with this
uh with this media outlet and um then
Elston puts his hand up and this is what
this is what the you know the the trans
activists on social media are using to
try to claim that this was not assault
at all is well he puts his hands on him
first no uh Elson puts his hand up to
establish personal boundaries which by
the way you have every right to do
nobody has the right to gulp right in
your face and scream at you you have
every right to establish your personal
boundaries and that's what he does he
puts his hand up the trans dude responds
by smacking him in the head and throwing
into the ground out
uh he feels entitled to his violent rage
the trans person does and for good
reason because the police think that
he's entitled to it too which is why
they did not arrest the assailant and
even later Justified the attack by
telling Elston and this is on camera
that it was a mutual fight
so if you are accosted by this drooling
rage mob screaming Fu in your face and
then smacking you in the face that is a
mutual fight
as far as the cops are concerned
but this is how we make trans people
visible I suppose by by giving them
carte blanche to do whatever they want
all the time
and they got some more visibility the
following day when uh Dylan Mulvaney
added to his long list of corporate
sponsorships with a new one from Bud
Light well then he announced the
partnership on Sunday listen
hi impressive carrying skills right I
got some Bud Lights for us so I kept
hearing about this thing called March
Madness and I thought we were all just
having a hectic month but it turns out
it has something to do with sports and
I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
cheers go team whatever team you love I
love too
okay
love ya okay break a leg
this is how persecuted uh these people
are I mean all a man needs to do is
announce that he's a woman and he'll be
immediately showered with more
endorsement deals than an NFL
quarterback gets
okay okay in fact one of the only
quarterbacks who Rivals Mulvaney's
sponsorship tally is Colin Kaepernick
and he's not even a quarterback
the only good news that I can see here
is that it should be very easy to
boycott Bud Light given that their beer
tastes like rain water siphoned out of a
tin bucket that's been sitting in your
backyard for three weeks I mean Bud
Light tastes very much like malaria and
rust and it also tastes like nothing at
the same time so it's kind of an
impressive concoction in that way but
not one that I would actually want to
consume on purpose the only people who
do want to consume it are Frat Boys or
55 year old bikers and nobody in between
those two extremes like literally nobody
else has ever had Bud Light at least not
in the last 20 years
which makes you wonder who this is meant
to appeal to
Okay who in either of those Target demos
would be more likely to purchase and
drink Bud Light now that a man in a
dress is adorning its cans
I mean how does this make good business
sense
the answer of course is that it isn't
being done in order to sell more
products it's being done as a signal as
a symbol as a sign of allegiance to the
trans agenda
and the way to Signal this Allegiance is
to constantly make trans people visible
even if they're already as visible as
any minuscule minority can possibly be
or has ever been in history
but it's still not enough It's never
enough it can never be enough
and that's partly because progressivism
can do nothing but March forward can do
nothing but you know progress
progressivism it progresses like bone
cancer eating away at its host until
there's nothing left to consume
but also partly because trans ideology
in particular is so flimsy it's so frail
that it's always on the verge of
collapse it's perched precariously on
this Edge and it must be aggressively
propped up all the time every second of
the day
the trans person individually barely
believes the claims he makes about
himself and his own identity his
self-perception is this superficial you
know ephemeral thing it's a lie that he
whispers constantly to himself and he
shouts it at the world it demands that
it be shouted back to him
no other group needs this kind of
support
because no other group is in a constant
state of trying to convince itself that
it exists
now there are many other groups in
modern America who demand special rights
and special privileges and entitlements
but the one thing they don't need is to
be constantly persuaded of their own
existence
and that's the real difference here
I'll do it for this portion of shows
move over members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you on uh tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]